welcome to this video a new part of
endgame strategy yeah this is a video
about a very classical theme good bishop
against bad bishop there are many
examples of course in chess where a good
Bishop is dominating a bad bishop and
will win the game at the end we need to
study lots of examples to really get ya
get all the points that come up in the
same game
I selected one position that is I think
fairly instructive it is a case where
black here in this case we have chronic
playing black playing nuke front vini um
where black it does not have its super
clear advantage in terms of the pawn
structure it is clear that he has the
better bishop as there is a pawn on d4
which is limiting its whites bishop and
black in relation to the keep on yonder
5 has the good one but it's not like
that wise has misplaced all its pawns on
the on the wrong color complex so it's
not a super trivial to really make
headway here this is why this is a good
example we should note that this was
played in 1990 in the European Junior
Championship so Finn really at the time
17 or 18 years old and cronic I think 15
years old so a junior event let's see
how chrome Nick proceeds it is his turn
to move here like to move and the the
first move is in fact absolutely
essential
what is Black's first move
he played g5 g5 is absolutely necessary
to get anywhere in this position why the
reason is that white as mentioned has
this misplaced pawn on d4 in a way this
place is maybe the wrong word but it's
not ideally placed in relation to
the bishop but other than that his bone
structure is not that bad
what black wants to do and now actually
can force is to advance his G pawn to g4
which fixes the pawn on g3 this means
that white has two weaknesses actually
and two pawns that are placed on the
wrong color complex on the dark squares
where the bishop is if white on the
other hand would have if he has time to
play g4 then the whole thing is just not
as bad let's say if black would have
played nothing looks like that then
white goes here and for example after
stuff like g6 unko g4 and this is not as
critical yeah this pawn is defensible
and cannot be attacked by the bishop
very important by the f6 Bishop so black
absolutely has to strike first with the
move g5 kramnik of course played that
yeah white really am it has nothing
great that he can do even king of three
and black when g4 in fact what is the
next step what we have accomplished now
is fixed two weaknesses great but what
next the big issue is that we can only
win if we somehow manage to enter with
our King without the king we won't make
any substantial progress and this spec
basically am yes suggest to suggest the
next maneuver the white king always will
stay here on III or d3 to block the
excess to the crucial e4 square this
means that we have to find some other
route and well checks just is quite
illogical in game sometimes the only
route can be all the way back here on
the Queen side
however if we are doing that we will
yeah
move the King away from those pawns and
Wyatt might get into a 4/4 counter play
so if we play a very careless move like
that white will even win the porn
immediately so this means that we have
to control therefore square therefore
crumb milks move is very logical not
King in six of course but Bishop e7
bishops III Bishop d6 we have improved
our Bishop this Bishop now attacks this
weakness which we had fixed at the start
of the endgame and it makes sure that
the White King is not ever crossing this
this line yeah of course also this has
to be defended so why it was due to this
passive move teeny one yeah and now
black can start the second step of his
series of mini plans the King has to go
over here we go King C - yeah still what
next
isn't this like a fortress almost but
there is still one one bullet that that
we can fire of course a5 the only way
forward is really to exchange those two
pawns to make sure that the King can in
German it is the only way forward you
know we have no idea besides that except
that we cannot really win by by azúcar
swung on those two pawns without the
King there is nothing that can be done
yeah King b3 wrong was played now and of
course now a 4 this was the whole point
of the operation
yeah right now only has a very sad
choice he can take on a form we can
allow the move a3 yeah
if white tries to play this
this does make some sense of course if
black captures we all of a sudden cover
all the crucial squares is white but
black has the stronger move a three
that's very important
King b1 oops
Bishop to b4 yeah and this is of course
now very nice for black what should I do
now yeah you cannot really trade and to
Bishop F to Bishop d2
is also very nice we have this this
additional resource of the Kings now
yeah we should briefly look at the king
of corn and Kim if white white captures
we win it then the deep one is simply
too far advanced plus the space
advantage this is a very important point
this bishop before to break through
white however he captured on a form and
now black takes yeah this is now a very
pure example where white has two
weaknesses and black has managed to
enter with the King if white plays now
he played Bishop f2 but let's say he
plays King C - you know just to look at
alternatives
what is blacks play now what should
black do now yeah we can go King to a3
and here we see a key element of almost
all endgame types
Zuka Swan now it's white to move and
whatever he does he's not going to be
happy about it
if white yeah white cannot move along
this diagonal as g3 draws if you go here
like we'll make progress with that
intending this or after 23 coming to b3
this is something that we will see in
the game and well there is no move
this is why white played Bishop f3 f2 it
is it is leading now to the already
mentioned position King b3 and again
we're dealing with the Zuke's wrong
situation white can only now shuffle
between those two two squares if he
allows the black king to approach then
this pawn will fall it's impossible now
for y to defend the pawn simply oops
simply a route like that we win the pawn
Bishop e1 was played King B - yeah and
again zooks won this move is not helping
any other King with me approach so what
else is there there really is only again
the Bishop F to move and now King c1
black is advancing further and what
should why Dumas really am there's
really nothing that he can do he played
the the check King be one Bishop F -
yeah and now what what is the next step
we have the activated the King - that
most and any King move now like this or
this is answered by the this side step
so the King cannot move it is a temple
fight for temple with the bishop with
this bishop and what is the way forward
like now played this move which is very
strong as white now really doesn't have
any any great alternative he played King
III but we can also look at other other
options Bishop III for example we have
King u 1 also having this idea King you
won Bishop f4 you should be for it is a
very very slow process but ultimately we
will get to one of the pawns at just the
case where there are two weaknesses as
mentioned that are fixed and we have
entered with the King normally two
weaknesses that are also somewhat far
apart plus an active King that is some
is invading should win the game view to
Zeus one motifs and here White is
ultimately helpless against the loss of
one of those pawns in the game if we go
back down
after Bishop III when really played King
III check on c1 King to d3 and now the
final stroke very nice Bishop d2 yeah
very nice Dukes one what should watch
you now the King cannot move you have to
move the bishop yeah he went to e3
alternatively there is only bishop g1
what else until all this is kinda said
but it is also quite quite easily
winning now this is Bishop is now I just
killed him and coming over so in the
game you went Bishop b3
gem and now of course not the trade but
we should be one attacking the weakness
Bishop f4 only move Bishop f2 yeah and
now the problem is that white is running
out of moves
what should he play played Bishop e5
King e1 yeah and this is very simple so
white needs to do something about that
he has to go for some sort of counter
play with the King this is why you went
King to c3 yeah and now black can
actually return Keaney to the return is
maybe the wrong word but switch
directions King before the king of three
King c5 and King e4 and this is the
absolutely final touch this is the
TechEd
this is attacked d5 is protected and
white now loses one of the pawns due to
Zeus one just excellent right this was a
very nice and clean demonstration of
good against bad bishop it is very
important to
to note that you can really only win if
we jump back a little bit to the to the
start of the whole thing you can only
really win or let's say hope for win
because it's still a difficult thing to
actually win at the end as we have seen
it required precision when you have you
should have two weaknesses to attack at
least two points on the wrong wrong
color complex and some idea to enter
with the king
note that in this kind of situation if
we just let's say change the position
like that the whole thing is just a draw
there is absolutely no way for black to
enter the position white will just
shuffle on this two squares probably get
the bishop over to have two or something
like that and then just stay the whole
thing is only a win due to that idea to
enter with the king if you cannot enter
with the King you cannot win so I'm a
very nice example if we switch back to
the actual game we see that here the
whole thing is some evolving around some
step-by-step planning Bishop to d6 first
yeah getting this setup hindering the
White King from entering and then we go
to the second stage where black is
pushing his a pawn to enter with the
King yeah and after that we have to
activate the King to the utmost this in
this case we were able to go to d1 and
then it's about Zeus one this is really
a concrete calculation we need to
calculate step by step and precisely how
to use oops one to finally get to one of
the key squares like f3 Entente form you
know this is a matter also of patience
but very often you are in a situation
where you can also yeah consider very
carefully what to do because you're not
very much in a hurry those kind of firm
zooks one situation setting up those
it's very often not like a one-time
chance you can maneuver a bit and try
out various setups it's often a good
idea not to rush things and just see and
probe around a little bit and only then
really get to a point where you make
substantial progress there's no shame in
repeating moves on trying to improve
slowly yeah I hope you enjoyed this very
nice simple that very nice example of
good against bad bishop there are many
more complex positions that can be
examined and I'm pretty sure I will
return to this at a later stage and a
serious thanks for watching